[Music]
[Music]
staying on
hey miss Potts if you find this
recording don't feel bad about this part
of the journey use the end
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun than it sounds
food and water ran out four days ago
boxers don't run out tomorrow morning
I've been when I drift off I will dream
about you it's always you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
animus did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
you wiped out 50% of all living
creatures
we lost all of us
lost friends you lost family
you lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we
met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany is just an old message that's me
can you buzz me in everyone Bonnie made
a friend in class oh she's already
making friends
no no she literally made a new friend I
want you to meet porky he's a spool yes
yeah I know
porky is the most important toy to
Bonnie right now we all have to make
sure nothing happens to him woody we
have a situation I am NOT a toy I was
paper soup salad maybe chili and then
the trash but God can't porky a bourbon
why am i alive you're Bonnie's toy you
are going to help create happy memories
that will last for the rest of her life
huh come on beau hi my name is Gabby
Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boy what are
you doing here no time to explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff woody always come in to
the rescue Bonnie needs 40 woody who
needs a kid's room when you can have all
of this Wow woody are we going to Bonnie
we have to finally do but what do you do
jump out of a moving vehicle let's go
where you gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this loss toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can be
good you can't teach this old toy new
tricks if you'd be surprised
Bonnie we're going home for tea
on my way what do you is Finity at me
kids lose their toys everyday I was made
to help a child I don't remember it
being this hard weddy somebody's
whispering in your ear
everywhere I go I see his face she's
really missin ya missin - I don't think
Tony would have done what he did if he
didn't know that you were gonna be here
after he was gone
you gonna be in next autumn and now well
no I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation heads up
Nick freeze calling me I don't really
want to talk to me resolve why because
if you don't talk to him and I have to
talk I don't want to talk
you sent Nick Fury to voicemail I gotta
go you do not ghost Nick Fury dorks
what's up we're just talking about the
trip oh I think MJ really likes me when
I first went alone you're a very
difficult person to contact spider-man
this is mr. Veeck we're gonna use
someone like you on my world new world's
bik is from Earth just not ours the snap
to our home in our dimension we have a
job to do you're coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
what about Thor offworld captain panel
unavailable but who's the funny
neighborhood spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want Peter I want to go back on
my trip with the girl you I really like
you tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not
I mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
it's always feel like I put my friends
in danger the world needs the next
Ironman you're going to step up or not
[Music]
here I work with spider-man you were
through Slayer
I want what spider-man not for
spider-man
[Music]
life's not fair is it my little friend
while some are born to feast others
spend their lives in the dark
[Music]
begging for scraps
[Music]
everything you see
exists together in a delicate balance
[Music]
while others assists for what they can
take a true King says as to what he can
do
[Music]
run away Simba
never recover
you must take your place
and the circle of life
[Music]
[Music]
you stumbled upon an opportunity
I can make you rich rich enough to
impress a princess
what would I have to do there's a Cave
of Wonders
bring me the land
oh great ones and summons me I stand by
my oath loyalty to wishes three I'm
kidding Russians
[Music]
hey can you make me a prince there is a
lot of gray area in make me a prince I
could just make you a prince oh no you
look like a prince on the outside but I
didn't change anything on the inside
Showtime no I'm in charge okay I say
when it's done really
I thought a princess could go anywhere
not this princess do you trust me
[Music]
to my right is bounty law series lead
and JIT cahill himself rick dalton and
to my left is rick stunt-double cliff
booth so Rick explain to the audience
exactly what it is a stunt double does
actors are required to do a lot of
dangerous stuff cliff here is meant to
help carry the load is that how you
describe your job cliff what carrying
his load adds about right
[Music]
my hands are registered as lethal
weapons we get into a fight I
accidentally kill you I go to jail
anybody accidentally kills anybody in a
fight to go to jail it's called
manslaughter
[Music]
[Music]
that was the best acting I've ever seen
in my whole life thank you
[Music]
[Music]
war is a universal language I know
renegade so to pursue never occurred to
me that one might come from above
space invasion
big car chase
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
til I met you today so you're not from
around here it's hard to explain
I keep having these memories
I see flashes
[Music]
I think I had a life here
[Music]
but I can't tell if it's real
[Music]
we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this
you
I'm not what you think I am
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home they seem nice
but don't buy it it gets real
gameofthrones around here dude just mess
around you look at me and you're like
why so dark you're just able to foster
kid you've got it all if you could have
one superpower what would you think
everybody chooses flight you know why so
they can fly away from this conversation
no cuz hero's fly well you need your
fake family to stand up for you hey
sorry about that
Billy Batson I choose you escape Ian
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir
wait for you okay Shazam
Billy you're the only person I know that
knows anything about this Cape Crusader
stuff tonight this is crazy right what
are your superpowers superpowers dude I
don't even know how to pee in this thing
[Music]
okay why are you talking your postcards
your phone cards like a bad guy right
you have full immunity I will prove
you're dead sorry about your window yeah
welcome for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]
welcome baby jumbo all family here
no matter how small
[Music]
[Music]
that's something very rare
you have wonder
[Music]
you have to stick
you have magic
[Music]
come with me
together we could soar on the elephant's
wings
what's happening were they taking her
take that mo back inside but Jesus mom
do something she needs us look at me
we're gonna bring your mama huh
he doesn't look like magic to me
[Music]
your children need you to believe in
you can do a jumbo show
[Applause]
sly baby
[Music]
our world is changing the mass
extinction we feared has already begun
and we are the cause we are the
infection
[Music]
but like all living organisms the earth
unleashed a fever to fight this
infection its original and rightful
rulers the Titans for thousands of years
these creatures have remained in hiding
around the world
and unless all the titans are found our
planet will perish and so will we
they are the only guarantee that life
will carry on
[Music]
you are out of your goddamn minds I am
sorry but this is the only way
[Applause]
[Music]
long live the king
[Music]
does it bother you that I'm not too
completely human you were the most human
person I have ever met
[Music]
didn't I tell you to be home before dark
I just lost track of time
bleedin you have to be responsible or
[Music]
someone very special
hey kid not just a teenage girl hey
what's your problem you can't remember
what do you mean doc found you in the
scrap yard so you must be from out there
and I'm just an insignificant girl
that's what they want you to think
I'm not your daughter I don't know what
I am I do you have the most advanced
weapon ever
but that's just a shell it's not bad or
good that part's up to you
I do not stand by
in the presence of evil
she's threatening the natural order of
things
tonight is not a game
I need you to destroy the girl called
Aleta
we made the biggest mistake of your life
and what's that
under estimating Who I am
[Applause]
once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh did
I interrupt you brooding just now
times have changed you need to change
with them we have to be tough and
battle-ready
Oh
hurry the door is slowly closed
oh the pain it's Jane so cold see that
wasn't so bad nothing got in
it's all my fault
hang on your fronds planning we're going
to save Lucy to be destroyed
you mind if I save your life not at all
who are you names Rex danger vest galaxy
defending archaeologist cowboy and
Raptor trainer I don't get it
we'll help me rescue my friends you
don't want to go anywhere near that
sistar system it's ruled by an alien
coin only the toughest you're gonna get
out of there alive
i'm mcqueen whatever I would not be I'm
getting super evil vibes here I could
change my form to something else if this
makes you more comfortable
hey guys they'll go back
don't worry was much more palatable on
your feet
who are you I'm your worst nightmare Oh
me when I'm late to school and I forgot
my homework and my pants are made of
pudding no I don't so there I was woke
up with a heavy case of amnesia in the
middle of nowhere the only clue to my
past is Harry's name and an address
inside this hat so I made my way to the
apartment and that's when I found you
and your stapler gonna loosen a shoe so
you're talking Pikachu with no memories
who's addicted to caffeine I could stop
it whatever I want these are just
choices another round extra shot I don't
know maybe hair got in too deep and
mixed up the wrong crowd that kind of
thing
you can talk to humans and I can talk to
Pokemon and if you want to find your
pops we're gonna need you to know I
don't need a Pokemon what about a
world-class detective Harry is still
alive case closed
but still open until I solve it
all right here it is Harry faked his own
death or somebody else fake Terry's
death
[Music]
Harry fake somebody else is dead that
last one doesn't work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
now obviously I've done what this pups
before so I'll just do it again hey bud
what are you doing I can't do when
people are watching
[Music]
that's a twist that's very twisty
yeah no he's barely moving don't tell
him that
oh he's on a fight quick get in front of
him stop oh no he's going down hard Tim
should have worn a helmet
I told you that I want to go to that
festival in Sweden no you said it would
be cool to go yeah and then I got the
opportunity and I decided they'd do it
you going I just wish he would have told
me that's all do it she needs a
therapist you've been wanting out of
this stupid relationship for like a year
now and don't forget about all of the
beautiful Swedish women you'll need in
June okay guys that's not her again
seriously babe what's happening then
I was so very sorry to hear about what
happened
I invited Danny become a Sweden you know
what she's been going Christian says
you've got this Fashion Week planned
it's sort of a crazy festival special
ceremonies and dressing up kissing is
fun
unbelievable welcome and happy midsummer
school what time is it 9:00 p.m. that
can't be right the sky's blue this is 1
9 p.m. is like here
how long have you two been together just
over three and a half years four years
really yeah what do you think it's like
another world tomorrow's a big day is it
scary what is it it has special
properties what am I going through
we just need to acclimate I don't want
to acclimate I won't go
absolutely not what's happening
that's why you look so guilty right now
because you know
we only do this every 90 years
I was most excited for you to come
[Music]
you have no idea what's coming
mr. wit broke the rules
I trust you understand the repercussions
if he survives John when X communicator
is now
you shouldn't be here
nice suit
good to see you too I need your help
after this we are less than even there's
no escape for you
my high table wants your life
would you help set the mood frown you
guessed
let us begin our service is still
off-limits
what do you need
guns lots of guns you think you can take
John with you got a nasty surprise
coming I've been looking forward to
meeting you
for long time
and so far you haven't disappointed
we could keep this up as long as you'd
like
but this only ends one way
[Music]
all of this for what because of a puppy
wasn't just a puppy
[Music]